Kaye I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab our topic today is
mathematics mathematics and mathematics.
This post is our topic but actually we
do have a gripping story for you coming
up now from our producer
Shawn Wheeler. Hey sorry. Hey.
And this is about math right. Yeah.
Well math and friendship really.
And I heard it from Steve Strogatz.
He's a mathematician at Cornell University
and he's been on the show once or
twice. OK.
And we sat down in the studio and he
told me about you back up and tell me a
little bit about high school and about
his high school math teacher Don Jaffrey.
Well there were several striking
and peculiar things about him.
I mean probably the first thing is that
he was physically incredibly impressive.
You hold the chalk between his enormous
fingers and right on the board the chalk
would pulverize with each stroke so that
there would be this cloud of chalk dust
all over him and his big sweater and
another thing that was very unusual about
him.
He'd be in the middle of the calculation
standing at the board chalk dust all
over him as usual.
Then he would space out and he'd get a
look in his eye a kind of faraway look
and then he'd say Oh this reminds me with
the hushed tone This reminds me of the
time Jamie Williams calculated the formula
for the end of term and the Fibonacci
sequence.
Who's Jamie with Jamie
Williams was a student at.
He was just a couple of years ahead
of Stephen and Mr. Jeffries Clark.
And that was part of the mystique.
You know that now he was graduated
and it was as if the secret was.
Was lost to the ages.
But the point was that he would talk
about a student with reverence with
reverence. Yeah.
What was very thrilling about that is
that there was this kind of chain that we
were now becoming part of.
Yeah. So then I'm off to college.
And it was it started very
early I started to write to him.
It was sort of like an annual tidbit.
Dear Mr. Joffrey here's the gem
that I learned this year in.
So Steve would write to him Mr. Joffrey
would write back add something ask him a
new question and then went on like that
for a while with Steve kind of still
being like a student and Mr.
Joffrey still like a teacher.
There was one moment though where.
Something new happened
where he wrote to me.
Asking for help.
He said a question came up in his class
about an elliptical swimming pool.
So you know picture a swimming pool.
Often there's a little border on the
edge of the swimming pool like a piece of
concrete that lines the pool you
stand on that part before jumping in.
And so the question was if you had an
elliptical swimming pool with a one foot
boarder around it is the outer edge
of the border. Also on the lips.
Something about that really appealed
to me it was a very nice math problem.
Probably there was a little bit of a show
off in me like I thought if I could do
this he's going to say something
nice. You'll become part of the panel.
Maybe he'll enter the pantheon they'll
start talking about me like they used to
talk about Jamie Williams.
So I stopped whatever I was doing and I
worked hard on that ellipse problem and
I figured out two or three different ways
too. Turns out it's never an ellipse.
If it cannot be an ellipse so sat down
and wrote back to Mr Joffrey about this
puzzle.
But I didn't just show him the answer.
I wrote the answer in a very loving
and gentle way that was meant to be
empathetic.
That is I know where you're coming from
and I'm going to just start from scratch
to lead you from where you are to where
you need to be to solve this problem.
In other words Steve acted like he was
the teacher and Mr. Joffrey played along
and this was such a generous
thing in retrospect.
The humility the modesty the kindness
in playing the role of a student.
It's like he knew that that's what I
needed and man I loved it. I would.
I couldn't wait for the next question.
And as Steve went off to graduate school
to become a math professor himself he
and Mr. Joffrey kept
writing to each other.
In fact they were writing
to each other quite a lot.
There was one sequence in March of 1989
where we wrote to each other almost
every day.
He sent me a puzzle. I worked on it. I
showed him a really beautiful answer.
He expressed kind of ecstasy
and seeing this answer
it was kind of a mathematicians dream
correspondence of puzzles and equations.
And Steve loved it. But every so often.
Mr. Joffrey would.
Break the routine a little bit.
He would say things about that
he was doing some jazz piano gig.
He would sometimes write
about he had three sons.
He would talk about them a little
bit and you know I feel embarrassed.
It feels mean but I remember not liking
those parts of the letters and I didn't
write about that.
I mean I would say maybe I was playing
some tennis or but I have lines in some
of my letters that say after a few of
those sentences. Okay enough stalling.
Here's the math problem.
But then in later years he would almost
pointedly ask me things like there was a
time when he said that rumor has it that
you're engaged. We wish you the best.
If this is true.
And guess what I got
my letter back to him.
I didn't say anything. You remembered
like thinking not to respond or just.
Well I I I can tell you what was going
on which is that I was already in couple
therapy with my fiance say you know like
in that time the letters were a kind of
refuge from all that.
That is we could go into this pristine
world of math where things are simple and
logical and.
Well-ordered.
There may have been part of me
that felt like I'll come on it.
This is the one place where it's all.
Perfect
but over the years that perfect world
got a little less perfect because his
older son died Marshall died
Marshall died when he was only
27 and uh I didn't ask about it.
Can you believe this. I feel so sick
about this when I think about it now.
So you were just right back.
Oh I've got another poll.
Got another math problem for you.
Look at this.
Yeah
and then more than 20 years
into this relationship.
Letter writing Mr. Joffrey retired and
now that he couldn't teach anymore he'd
write to me he'd show me these beautiful
math problems that he would make up for
himself usually about hawks flying
over the earth and you know how much
spherical area can the hawks see
if it's at such and such altitude.
And what is happening at this time is
that now I have just gotten married and
we've started having kids and I'm
not answering his letters anymore.
They're sitting in their
envelopes stacking up.
He's writing them faster than
I can answer him a lot faster.
And then at one point I got
one more letter from Mr.
Joffrey except as soon as I
looked at the envelope I could see
that something was really very wrong.
His handwriting didn't look normal.
That my address my name was written in a
craggy like shaky shaky and I knew what
that looked like because my dad wrote
like that when he had Parkinson's.
So I thought what what is this.
And I opened the letter and the first
sentences eek. I just had a mild stroke.
I didn't write back to him right away.
I didn't call him
and then just a couple
months later my brother died
very suddenly. And.
He heard about it from someone else and
immediately wrote to me how you know
that he was very he and his wife had heard
and they were very sorry to hear that
my brother had died. That to me was
you know I still had never said I'm sorry
about Marshall all those years ago and
it kept nagging at me.
Why won't you talk to him beckoning
and you obviously care about him.
It's sort of like an in math.
There's this concept of bifurcation
which really means a fork in the road a
splitting when the forces
on a system get too large.
There can be a moment when the
dynamics of that system change.
Abruptly.
This was a moment of bifurcation.
I should have just said how sorry
I was to hear about about Marshall.
So I I thought I gotta go talk to him
and ask him Can I come to your house.
You know he seemed a little reluctant
about it but you know. Okay fine.
So I bought a little pocket tape recorder
just a cheap thing drove up Route 95
to his house in Connecticut on the shore
knock on the door here the piano that
was playing inside Stop.
He comes and rushes to see me and we
give each other hugs take out a big plate
of cold cuts and say let's
sit out on the porch.
Does that work well.
So we're we're eating and be recording
and then he takes out his journal.
I decided that I would keep a journal
since I was retired where he's drawn
pictures of all kinds of birds and here's
a picture of me doing an eagle watch
out in the Connecticut River.
And there's a lot of stuff back
in his typical way. I don't know.
This is a bird it's moved up from
the south too. You never saw these.
Well what some people call buzzards.
Yeah they've they've moved up here and.
This is one of my favorite birds.
It's a Marsh Hawk and it
flies low over the meadows.
More about that.
Hank says I'm going to take you over
to see a rough legged Hawk. Now.
He didn't say we're going to see
if we can see a rough legged hawk.
He produced.
And I'm thinking to myself I don't
not really interested in this.
I want to talk about him about all these
things that are that we never talked
about that are emotional hard things
like what happened. How did your son die.
Have a lot of work.
They're just trying to make eyes for
it in extra hours to pay guys extra.
There was a fidgeting feeling inside
me and benefits and right other stuff.
And there was a pause.
My heart was beating fast.
Then I thought I'm gonna ask him.
So I don't think we ever talked
about Marshall but I want it I I did.
I asked what.
I didn't really know him either but I
know that he died very young and I know
what what happened.
You know what happened to Marshall. Well.
You know.
That's not what I want to talk about.
And I think he's gonna say that's
something we don't talk about.
Well it was he he had ever as a star.
Energy.
He did. He had a wonderful 27 years.
Music was gone. It was so beautiful.
And so and so we went to
mass so uplifting and sweet.
He'd be at home and we'd sit around
the piano and I'll get out there.
Cole Porter songbook I just turned to
a page something that he'd never seen.
He could sight read it play it
and sing it all in one time.
Well that's an I thought.
This guy's got a multi-channel
line that I wish I had.
You know he talked about what a
great what a great life he had.
In his 27 years in the waning moments.
He'd stay up all night long playing the
piano just the house which is filled
with beautiful music
and he had made plans to get a job at
the New England Conservatory and things
like that. But. The fates were wrong.
Oh yeah. We miss.
Was was that I mean in that moment
did it change the way you see him.
Well
change I have to tell
you how that day ended.
So we talked more record and I asked him
at one point do you think Marshall had
a religious feeling and he said oh yeah
he does think he felt close to having to
come to terms with somebody out there.
Yeah that was a good thing that
that I think he went peacefully.
Then and actually conversation drifted
to easier things like calculus problems.
And we talked to more about math and
then he said How about a swim or let's go
to gym I should go out to the beach and
I'd like to do something where I get
outdoors a.
So we did go to the beach and it was a
beautiful evening and there were waves.
Coming in from Long Island Sound.
In fact we were talking
about a math problem about
waves about 40 analysis which
is really about well infinity and the
fact that if you take an infinite number
of simple waves you can create any shape
of wave you want as long as it's a wave
that repeats.
But then Mr. Jaffrey asked But how do
you create waves that don't repeat waves
that change sometimes
waves don't exactly repeat.
They can grow or die out.
And Steve told them that to
deal with those kinds of waves.
You need a different kind of infinity.
Not the kind where you just keep adding
and adding and adding numbers but the
kind that sits in the space between two
numbers this higher kind of infinity
then than Don had thought about before.
Thanks to Susan Miller because you
interviewed Steven produced that story.
Thanks to Steve Strogatz who has a book
out now which tells this very story
called the calculus of friendship.
I'm Jad Abumrad. Three
seconds to do you are Robert.